معنى الان في استوديو التغطيه هنا رئيس
جمهوريه مقدونيا الشماليه السيد ستيفو
بنداروس سيد بن داوكس مرحبا بكم معنا شكرا
لوجودك معنا تحدثت في جلسه اليوم عن الحرب
الدائره في اوكرانيا الحرب التي شنتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا ووزنت بين معسكريين
معسكر الديمقراطيه ومعسكر الاوتوغرافيه
والاستبداد الذي تمثله الديكتاتوريه
الحاكمه في روسيا حاليا كيف ترى افاق هذه
الحرب
من بعيد
الايام الاولى للحرب التي انطلقت السنه
الماضيه في شهر فبراير بالنسبه الى القسم
الديمقراطيه من العالم الجواب واضح
قسم او هذا الجانب يواجهه او يناضل ضد
الاوتوغرافيه ضد الاستبداد ونحن نسعى الى
مواجهه من خلال
الامم المتحده بالنسبه الينا في مقدونيا
ودول شمال الاطلسي يجب ان نتوحد وان نضع
حدا نقول لا تتخطوا هذا الحظ فاكهاني اكثر
لاي دوله بان تحتل دوله اخرى لان حقوق
الانسان والحريه يجب ان تكون مضمونا
الجميع في هذا العالم هذا هو السبب الذي
دعانا
الحرب في توحيد الصف من اجل ان ندعم
اوكرانيا ليس فقط
بل لاننا نحن كم مقدونا دوله صغيره وتاريخ
علمنا انا معاناه كبيره حين ياتي احدهم
اكثر قوه منك وياخذ منك حريتك نستمر
طريقه اخرى لكي
نوقفشلنا نحن كاد والجمقراطيه انا فشلنا
هذا المره
جين
لنظام بوتين لن تكون اوكرانيا اخر دوله
تحتلها
اليوم تحدثت وعرضت عن رضاك عن مستوى
التعاون والتضامن والوحده همم بين دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بين الدول في القاره
الاوروبيه وكذلك مع الولايات المتحده
ولكنك اعرضت عن بعض المخاوف من ان هذا
المستوى من الوحده قد يتلاشى بانتهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا لماذا لماذا هذا يعني
هذه المخاوف
دقيقه
كلنا يجيبوا ان نوحد هذا الجبهه هذه
الديمقراطيه وندعم اوكرانيا من اجل التصدي
للدكتور سوريا والاحتلال الجميع يتحدث
حاليا
في اوكرانيا باسرع ما يمكن ان يستعيد
الاوكرانيون بلدهم من المحتل هذا سوف يحصل
طبعا بكل تاكيد ولكن ماذا في اليوم الذي
يليه
تحريرها
داخل اوروبا وايضا بين موضوع للاخره
اوكرانيا كلنا نعدل من اجل النفس القضيه
لا وهي حقوق الانسان ولكن اريد ان ارى
داتا الحرب مع اوكرانيا ان تستمر هذه
القيام وتسمر وحده الصف التي نتحدث عنها
الناس
في العالم
حره هناك بعض الشعوب التي لا تزالت عن
العبوديه
هل هذا امر واقعي استمرار هذه هذا المستوى
من التضامن والوحده وتذكر دائما القيم
التي
تحدثت انكم تدافعون عنها بعد انقضاء
الحلقه الحرب العالميه الثانيه كانت حربا
اكبر بكثير بكثير من تلك الدائره الان في
اوكرانيا ومع ذلك لم تستوعب البلدان
الاوروبيه او تستوعب بلدان العالم هذا
الدرس او تعيه جيدا
وعادت القاره الاوروبيه للحروب مجددا في
التسعينيات ثم الان همم يعني ما مدى
واقعيه هذا الطرح
[موسيقى]
جرت
انتم وحقون انتم محقون نعم
لن ننسى انه بنهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه تاسست الامم المتحده كل الدول
الديمقراطيه اكثر من مره في العام في
الامم المتحده
وتناقشه
التي خرجنا بها بعض الحرب العالميه
الرهيبه
كل الدول
مصطفى نعيش في فوضى عارمه
والنزاعات والحروب
[تصفيق]
العام 2014
بالنسبه لجمهوريه مقدونيا الشماليه
الحتميات الجغرافيه وضعكم بين او ااا في
كدوله مجاوره لكل من صربيا وكوسوفو في وقت
واحد الى اي مدن يؤثر ذلك على وضع بلادكم
وتسريع طلب انضمامها للاتحاد الاوروبي
ودمجها في هذه المنظومه
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث تاريخيا
المنطقه بمثابه برميل بارود من طاقه
باستدامه استقرارها
عامه
الاطراف
مستمر فقط
انضم الى انيته لكم هناك دول اخرى تنتظر
دورها دعونا لا ننسى انه بالنسبه الى
استقرار وازدهار الشعوب وتحسين مستوى
معيشتها من المهم ان ننضم الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لقد بدانا المفاوضات وهناك عدد
من الدول الاخرى التي تفاوض على الانضمام
على العضويه ونحن نريد ان نصير جزءا او
منطقتنا قصيره
الى السلام فعلا
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد ستيفو بنداروفكي رئيس
جمهوريه مقدونيا الشماليه شرفنا بك معنا
في هذا البرنامج